en mars 2000
les bouddhas géants de la vallée de
bamiyan en afghanistan vieux de près de
deux millénaires
vivent leurs derniers instants
[Musique]
je me souviens très exactement d'abord
parce qu'il y avait eu des annonces de
ce projet de destruction avoir pensé
qu'on allait laisser détruire deux
oeuvres qui était fondamental pour
l'histoire de l'humanité et que nous
n'allions pas bougé
j'ai pensé que mon animal s'ils
n'étaient pas capables de se mobiliser
j'avais pour les oeuvres de l'esprit des
choses si importante pour l'humanité
alors c'est qu'il allait mal
[Musique]
pas
formé au fc chooz comme je dis ans mais
a plus rien n'y a pas une sensation est
fort qu'eux voire la destruction de
quelque chose ou on ne trouve pas le
sens de cette instruction et ces images
sont encore prêts phoque
quand vous les montrer à des petits
enfants et vous expliquer le contexte
ils ont du mal à comprendre pourquoi une
oeuvre d'art qui représente des siècles
et des siècles d'histoire peut être
l'objectif d'une destruction aussi
précise
rires à melbourne
[Musique]
la destruction des bouddhas de bamiyan
par les talibans a marqué le début d'une
nouvelle ère de tombouctou à jaca de
palmyre à mossoul le patrimoine culturel
a fait l'objet en ce début de xxième
siècle d'une destruction délibérée sans
précédent
[Musique]
jarret la mémoire de l'humanité est
devenue une cible est l'instrument d'une
guerre d'un nouveau genre
on peut en effet considérer que depuis
vingt ans il ya comme une explosion de
ce type d' attaque du patrimoine je
pense qu'elle s'explique surtout par la
médiatisation content que les
terroristes ont fait le patrimoine a
toujours été instrumentalisée mais il
est aujourd'hui dans une société
mondialisée où les images sont
immédiatement partager montré des images
de destruction du patrimoine s'est
montré leur conquête d'un territoire
[Musique]
sow et des groupes extrémistes ont vu
dans la destruction du patrimoine un
moyen de mieux se faire connaître et de
montrer au monde notamment à tous ceux
qui considèrent que le patrimoine est
important que pour eux c'est ce
patrimoine avait aucune valeur ils ont
compris que le patrimoine était quelque
chose qui unissait le monde et que
c'était finalement de ballons gâchés
donc le patrimoine devient un enjeu de
guerre
quand on touche au patrimoine on touche
à l'identité des gens ont tous fait leur
identité en février 2015 à mossoul au
nord de l'irak
l'état islamique met en scène la
destruction méthodique du musée de la
ville
[Musique]
ironie de l'histoire les islamistes
commettent leurs crimes en utilisant les
codes d'une société qu'il rejette une
vidéo de plus de quatre minutes avec
musique et ralentit comme pour
dramatiser un peu plus la scène
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
m
mais
le
[Musique]
mais
maintenant c'est au cachemire
recommencerai 12 h m d'hamar votre email
par là où douze ait élargi malik h
national al fani voyage a dit al maqam
l'anah amelia et admire par l'état omar
hilale work au bournat sciforma ben ayed
al qaeda à la coff mme abena femmes
aspirant mondial le match à l'étiquette
couloir 3 en 20 matches de la souris ou
carine maeder retour en d'al marabet
modèles de la marque
[Musique]
les graphiques sarcophage errani ou à ni
à la nro fait in a small world no nazo
tandem et de l'islam et à la mairie
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouah cas
plus
[Musique]
charest
[Rires]
[Musique]
avant tout cela au musée de mossoul et
ben on pouvait voir ces vestiges
assyriens qui nous entourent ici c'est
la masse où ils ont un corps de taureaux
ils ont aussi les cornes démultiplier
signe de leurs pouvoirs divins puisque
ce sont des créatures divines
il était destiné à protéger les passages
de portes dans la ville et dans le
palais
malheureusement le holà syrien du musée
de mossoul et celui qui a
particulièrement souffert à juste titre
on parle d'oeuvre martyrs c'était la
première fois que je voyais autant de
dégradations de dévastation
[Musique]
c'est assez symptomatique la destruction
d'un musée parce que amusé c'est fait
pour apprendre la profondeur de
l'histoire c'est aussi un pays qui
regarde son passé
amusé c'est fait pour ça et donc en
atteignant les musées on veut atteindre
cette mémoire on veut priver ces gens
des cultures qui les ont précédés le
signal est très fort à ses héros dont 10
h ces jeunes gens de la ville de mossoul
vous n'avez pas de passer donc vous
n'aurez pas de venir c'est demain
marielle mérode tard que l'île madame
affidés sur la foire car elle n'a jamais
allée ravi mehta qui donne honte à toi
tu atteins dit ana bela tarr in one dame
à la fin du mois
[Musique]
les djihadistes veulent effacer les
mémoires mais il adresse également un
message au monde sur fond d'une
idéologie extrêmement structurée attends
je crois comme on a fait une lecture
assez simpliste qui est de dire ils
veulent s'attaquer à l'idée de l'image 1
s'il avait une telle difficulté avec
l'image il n'utiliserait pas l'image
pour nous montrer la destruction des
images
[Musique]
au début de la petite vidéo que font les
gens de neige sur la destruction du
musée qu'est ce qu'ils disent il
mentionne le musée comme étant le musée
des anglais illzach rust la petite photo
où on voit la découverte du la masse où
on va l'animal est né à de ninive il
incruste cette petite photod'archives
c'est parfaitement documenté ils
connaissent suffisamment de choses sur
l'histoire de la discipline pour nous
renvoyer que ce qu'ils détruisent à
nouveau c'est l'oeuvre impie des
archéologues occidentaux c'est le musée
des anglais
[Musique]
il ya une profonde intelligence des
textes une profonde intelligence de son
histoire une idéologie extrêmement
construite ce n'est pas parce qu'elle
nous répugnent qu'elle n'existe pas si
on prend le cas de panne hier par
exemple qui est très frappant c'est le
sort différent qui a été réservé aux
sculptures provenant d y poser dans ces
tombes collectives qui étaient souvent
des tombes familiales
on se faisait représenter en buste au
musée qu'est ce qu'on voyait les bustes
de pamiers avait tous étaient des
visages est en revanche les sculptures
rester sur les sites sur place n'ont pas
été touchés elles ont été couvertes de
tissus et laissé en place
ça n'est pas une destruction aveugle
c'est une destruction argumenté
raisonnée vous avez construit une
histoire universelle
une histoire où tous les peuples ont été
organisés en un tableau général des
civilisations nous n'avons rien à faire
nous allons reconstruire nous ce qui
nous intéresse ce établies c'est-à-dire
un tableau de l'islam dominant les
autres religions les autres
civilisations ne nous intéresse pas et
quand elles sont sur notre sol soit
elles sont soumises soit elles sont
détruites
[Musique]
si les seize mausolée de tombouctou
érigé à la gloire de plusieurs saints
musulmans réduit en miettes à coups de
pioches et de barres à mine
alvaro qui était considéré par la
population comme le saint protecteur de
la ville c'est pour ça que j'ai détruit
son monument il n'y a qu'un seul
protecteur sédhiou
il y a un certain courants théologiques
iconoclaste qui a la volonté de détruire
le patrimoine servant de support à une
certaine vénération ce qui peut
expliquer que beaucoup de mosquées et de
tombeaux notamment ont été détruits donc
il y a eu une volonté exprimée
publiquement de détruire des symboles de
l'islam d'un certain islam pour en
imposer un autre d'islamisme c'est la
mort de l'islam je crois qu'on est aussi
dans cet état de dangers c'est à dire
que ce qui disparaît c'est aussi
l'histoire de l'islam
ce sont des monuments islamiques aussi
qui sont détruits
[Musique]
et
avec la destruction du musée de mossoul
puis quelques mois plus tard celle du
site antique de palmyre en syrie l'année
2015 marque un tournant
on est ici à l'unesco les encouragés par
la forte mobilisation internationale
contre le nettoyage que turenne qui
sévit aujourd'hui à tous les niveaux la
communauté internationale prend
conscience des pertes irrémédiables en
cours je crois que jusqu'à l'arrivée de
de ces destructions délibérées
il ne fait pas beaucoup de conscience il
n'avait pas beaucoup de jeu de la
tension politique sur d'hôtel de tels
cas mais après aujourd'hui on est on est
bien conscient de tout ça
[Musique]
les fanatiques s'en prennent aux vivants
mais ils s'en prennent aussi aux morts
ils s'en prennent à tout ce qui est
humaniste et à celles d'aujourd'hui de
demain est également à celle d'hier
je pense notamment à palmyre ou l'ancien
conservateur a préféré rester
il savait le sort qui l'attendait il a
été décapité par les bold dash qui ont
eux mêmes commis l'irréparable sur le
site
[Musique]
signe d'une certaine prise de conscience
mondiale la cour pénale internationale
s'empare de la question de l'atteinte au
patrimoine en 2016 le monde a pu mettre
un visage et un nom sur l'un des
commanditaires des destructions des
mausolées de tombouctou au mali son nom
ahmad al faqih al mahdi un touareg
salafistes membres du groupe en sardines
de chambers unanimis les centres sociaux
tonight sa condamnation pour crimes de
guerre par la cour pénale internationale
est une première
cela démontre que le patrimoine
aujourd'hui est reconnu comme un commun
à tous justement dans la construction de
ces sociétés est aujourd'hui c'est des
crimes de guerre c'est la première fois
que cette cour pour défendre la
patrimoine culturel d'une communauté
c'est donc l'occasion pour dire aux
victimes de ces attaques où nous avons
enfin entendu leurs cris de désespoir
le message contre l'impunité est très
important on ne peut pas dire c'est un
crime contre la guerre on ne fait pas
dire que il faut arrêter sans avoir
vraiment après appliquer la loi n'a à sa
finition dynamique et de ternate à nadia
et lili a failli dire à sa fille
[Musique]
je crois que c'est plus que symbolique
et même je crois que le fait qu'il a
qu'il ait reconnu sa culpabilité
c'est aussi important parce que ce
n'était pas quelqu'un qui est ignorant
c'est un professeur c'est une insigne
ans et je crois que ça aussi était
important est-ce qu'il répare les
destructions à ce qu'ils les empêche
est-ce qu'on va résonner médias dit je
crois que non pour autant est ce que il
faut s'arrêter de d'élaborer cette
réflexion sur un ce que veut dire la
destruction pense qu'il faut continuer à
en parler
peut-être qu'on ne se parle qu'à
nous-mêmes mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même le faire réparer les
destructions certains pays s'y attelle
en france l'initiative part du sénat par
la voix de bart isaac ari puis suit un
rapport du président du louvre
françois hollande propose la création
d'une nouvelle alliance pour le
patrimoine
nous sommes riches de tout ce que nous
avons de différent il va trouver un
allié de taille les émirats arabes unis
500 millions à 3,7 admirer les tableaux
à mars 2003
alice est très clairement vue d'une
mobilisation politique d'abord de la
france des émirats arabes unis de
l'arabie saoudite puis d'un de tous les
pays qui nous ont rejoints il ya d'abord
en effet une volonté politique forte
ensuite elle a été aussi le fait de
certains partenaires privés je pense
donc à ceux qui nous ont rejoints avec
leurs fondations et qui peut être eu en
voulut de l'action de la visibilité tout
de suite
nous allons continuer à lutter avec la
leaf avec toutes les fondations ici
présente avec l'unesco lutter pour
permettre justement que chacun de ces
lieux retrouve sa place sa fierté son
histoire là où l'unesco pilote
entièrement de grands chantiers de
restauration
alif finances des acteurs déjà en place
ong ou institutions culturelles
cette alliance met d'ores et déjà en
oeuvre en ce moment même ses premiers
projets en irak et au mali la nouvelle
organisation pour le patrimoine a lancé
depuis sa création en 2017
plus d'une centaine de projets dans 22
pays on peut faire parfois beaucoup avec
des dizaines de millions $ le coût moyen
d'un projet de la protection d'un psy de
sa rêverie réhabilitation c'est 200 300
400 mille cinq cent mille dollars ce qui
est ce qu'ils sont des montants souvent
élevés pour les pays dans lesquels nous
intervenons mais qui en réalité sont des
montants relativement modeste comparée à
d'autres types d'intervention
internationale
[Musique]
l'un des projets phares d'alif et la
renaissance du musée de mossoul pour un
million trois cent mille dollars
un projet initié par la smithsonian
institution de washington
et le musée du louvre à paris chadi la
lumière est intéressant ou pas du tout
en attendant la levée des restrictions
sanitaires les restaurateurs du louvre
forment leurs collègues irakiens à
distance à l'aide d'oeuvre similaires le
sculpteur daniel ibled et ses équipes
réalisent de courtes vidéos expliquant
les différentes étapes de restauration
de ces blocs ya plusieurs façon de
nettoyer une pierre le principe est
d'avoir justement un nettoyage homogène
on pas son nettoyage efficace
[Musique]
plus d'une trentaine de vidéos ont déjà
été réalisés grâce à elle peu à peu les
équipes du musée de mossoul reconstituer
préserve les fragments de ces oeuvres
meurtri j'ai fait la même intervention
il ya vingt ans maintenant presque avec
les oeuvres du musée de kaboul du musée
national de kaboul qui ont pareil tout
est ce qu ont été explosées en multiples
morceaux et qu'il a fallu commencer à
voir comment est-ce qu'on allait les
reconstruit c'est la même chose quoi
c'est la même zone d'après conflit c'est
le même la même désolation le même le
même regard que des gens de portes
dessus parce que c'est votre vie aia
pour n'arrive pas à mettre des mots sur
ce qui s'est passé et en même temps
l'expérience de kaboul m'a prouvé aussi
que c'est possible c'est possible ça va
être long ça va être difficile il va
falloir qu'il va falloir qu'il soit
extrêmement patient il va falloir qu'ils
nous fassent confiance
il va falloir qu'on les suive derrière
il s'agit pas de lancer une opération
puis de l'abandonner en plein milieu
parce que ça c'est catastrophique
fera juste une petite robe batin dessus
pour masquer la différence de tonalité
comme ça
[Musique]
avec des moyens humains financiers et du
temps et bien quelque part rien est
impossible
nous n'aurons jamais plus des oeuvres
intacte mais nous pourrons espérer avoir
des oeuvres qui renaissent et qui tout
en portant les traces de ce qu'elles ont
subi
et bien pourrait de nouveau être à venir
est telle qu'elle se présentait à
l'origine des dunlop et noah québec à
matane
[Musique]
à deux pas du musée se dressent les
restes de la grande mosquée al-nour i
[Musique]
son minaret pencher construit au 12e
siècle et est un emblème national
a nourri un lieu chargé en symboles
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'a boubacar al bagdadi a
proclamé son califat en 2014
[Musique]
ici aussi que trois ans plus tard ses
hommes devant l'imminence de leur
défaite ont préféré faire sauter ce lieu
vénéré par l'islam sunnite
[Musique]
à noter que trois ans après sa
destruction
le site est aujourd'hui sécurisé
l'ingénieur irakien omar taqa et son
équipe s'affaire au chevet du malade
la pose de capteurs de température de
pression et de niveau va leur permettre
d'analyser en temps réel l'état de la
structure
[Musique]
et donc là on a réussi à aligner toutes
les photos de l'intérieur du concours
d'icônes m
une start up française spécialisée en
modélisation 3d
les architectes vont pouvoir plonger
dans les entrailles des vestiges de ce
minaret presque millénaire
ce qu'on voit ici c'est un nuage de
points donc qui représente le site dans
dans tous ses détails
on se sert de cette forme de
visualisation pour pouvoir commencer à
faire les premières études on peut
mesurer par exemple des distances en
tout point du site est vérifiée y
compris ceux des zones qui sont
inaccessibles des dimensions
ce qui est intéressant également c'est
qu'on peut aussi rendre les choses
transparente
1 là par exemple ce qu'on voit cette
structure là en fait qu'on a un escalier
à double hélice c'est l'escalier qui à
l'intérieur du minaret
cet outil on s'en sert de la même
manière qu'un médecin va utiliser
l'imagerie médicale pour mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
du corps ça nous permet de comprendre
les et pc en des murs ça nous permet de
comprendre aussi le poids des structures
parce qu'on peut du coup mesures et des
volumes donc ces documents ils sont très
précieux pour les ingénieurs comme pour
les architectes justement pour évaluer
toutes les problématiques qui vont se
poser lors de la restauration
l'idée c'est de mettre au service de ce
monument et irakiens voilà les
meilleures compétences au monde dans
chacun des domaines
[Musique]
le projet de l'unesco est financé à
hauteur de 50 millions de dollars par
les émirats arabes unis
ce puissant royaume du golfe
également à l'origine d'alif porte une
attention grandissante au patrimoine
[Musique]
restauré
il y à ce point culture est un lien
particulier entre la france et les
émirats arabes unis à commencer par la
réalisation du louvre abou dhabi nous
considérons que que l'art la culture le
patrimoine doivent être enrichie
préservé avec attention et bienveillance
donc ce n'est pas anormal que ces deux
pays travaillent main dans la main
il savait que dans les émirats arabes
unis il n'y a pas tellement de
patrimoine et on voit aussi ces pays qui
sont à la recherche finalement de soi
d'acquérir un patrimoine
d'où le louvre abou dhabi par exemple
soit en participant à la sauvegarde et à
la restauration d'un certain nombre de
sites à travers le monde et une volonté
de la part des pays du golfe en
particulier de jeu dire de de rejoindre
sète ce patrimoine universel en
participant en finançant des projets de
reconstruction ou de revalorisation de
cela pour faire partie de cette même
communauté
ils ont vu là l'occasion d'être un
acteur d'être reconnu comme un acteur et
de pouvoir jouer un rôle et là encore de
faire en sorte que les pays avec
lesquels l'italie et les pays
occidentaux
du coup soit des alliés plus solide
parce que on a aussi ce lien par la
culture
[Musique]
signe de l'importance accordée au
patrimoine par les pays du golfe
l'arabie saoudite le grand voisin
wahhabite des émirats regarde
aujourd'hui différemment ces vestiges
pré islamique
en ce moment on arabie saoudite on est
en train de mettre en valeur le
patrimoine nabatéens al aoula mais c'est
extraordinaire ça n'a jamais été fait au
contraire c'était un patrimoine qui
était complètement caché les saoudiens
sont les détenteurs des lieux saints et
à partir du moment où il montre est là
ou là où ils vont en faire un site
touristique un site culturel
extraordinaire et bien c'est une preuve
que le patrimoine est quelque chose
d'important pour l'identité des gens et
elle permet elle permet de ne pas rester
enfermé dans une seule identité
l'attitude des autorités saoudiennes sur
l'histoire a complètement changé
ils admettent que la l'histoire dépanner
avec l'arrivée d'une dynastie ou d'une
autre et je crochète très intelligent et
par ailleurs c'est très juste fait que
ces deux pays se soient engagés dans la
leaf est pour nous fondamentale la
péninsule arabique est en train de faire
mouvement à nos côtés je trouve que
c'est très très important c'est une
façon de dire qu'ils sont d'un certain
islam et pas d'un autre il ya un moment
il y a un objectif qui est plus haut que
tout il faut savoir oublier les éléments
de dissensions il faut mettre en commun
ce qui nous réunit pour un intérêt
supérieur
[Musique]
dans toutes ces questions de protection
du patrimoine particulièrement certains
dénoncent l'attitude des européens en
disant que finalement on n'a pas de
leçon à donner
et c'est vrai puisqu'elle nous mêmes
nous avons les européens eux-mêmes
détruit une grande partie du patrimoine
européen et ensuite parce que parfois on
brandit aussi le passé colonial de
certaines de ces puissances donc je
pense que c'est une chance pour la
france d'avoir été rejoint dans ses
intentions par des pays comme les
émirats arabes unis et comme l'arabie
saoudite pour tenir un autre discours
que celui justement du point de vue
européen
ce n'est pas un point de vue européen
[Musique]
aux abords de la mosquée al nour i
le quartier voit peu à peu revenir des
habitants qui avaient fui l'occupation
comme khalil ismaël et moussa la
reconstruction du minaret est pour lui
une priorité
[Musique]
à la table et ennemi la dette et mon lit
des elfes tout ça mis à part baobab
c'est la première pour à 20 il lui a dit
au dôme a dit joe hart
ana lelas oye mba obame n'a gagné
montana thaçi fils d'hassan
[Musique]
monde
chez les cadets
tsonga mathieu et i'm on one aka bolt à
canon ricoh monde maritime à mal et de
talib un axe majeur a commenté me
charles comme un gars comme à monaco
henri tenue à dakar que les quidams
autres habits en mousseline claudio
arabia bas qu une cave de romilhac adil
el watan et jamy
man
et
[Musique]
restaurer le patrimoine peut-il
contribuer à la paix et aux liens
intercommunautaires
c'est tout l'enjeu des projets d'alif ou
de l'unesco
[Musique]
les émirats financent la reconstruction
de la grande mosquée mais aussi de deux
églises
ce qui est quand même un symbole de
souhaits d'un modèle de société où on
peut vivre ensemble et dans les
discussions qu'on peut avoir avec les
diffèrent divers gouvernements que ce
soit le gouvernement irakien
gouvernement émirati
le souhait est d'encourager les
chrétiens et les autres minorités à
revenir dans la ville de mossoul
alsa notre-dame de leur fait partie du
programme de restauration
l'église doit son nom à l'horloge
offerte par l'impératrice eugénie qui
ornait son clocher
les chrétiens de mossoul n'étaient pas
des étrangers
c'était des autochtones depuis des
millénaires si vous êtes musulman et à
la mosquée al nous lis votre horizon
c'est le clocher dalcin si vous êtes
alsa ce que vous voyez c'est le minaret
de la grande mosquée donc pour chacun de
nous c'est important que l'autre
reviennent à la vie
aujourd'hui reconstruire le patrimoine
c'est un signe fort envoyé à toutes les
composantes du pays
investir dans la pierre c'est aussi
investir dans l'humanité ça veut dire
que quand on prend le temps de façonner
une pierre de sculpter les détails on
pense à la prochaine génération
si ceux qui ont la charge de recontrer
habilité ça va associer les diverses
communautés les diverses religions et
diverses responsables culturels
ce peut être l'occasion de constituer
des étapes communauté globale
je pense que là le le patrimoine tt pour
les djihadistes un sujet de haine de
destruction peut être demain une source
de d'entente de compréhension quand on
intervient quand on soutient des projets
de réhabilitation du patrimoine
on a l'espoir que ce projet là
contribuent au vivre ensemble au
dialogue entre communautés à la
stabilité et la paix dans la région
kevin regroupe des fabricants comme
younes duret having been ripd une somme
cassis ti fred can be with somebody ofen
that because you find a way to show that
la tapisserie 10 ou 20
[Musique]
mais dans une ville comme mossoul
autrefois peuplé de 20% de minorités
chrétiennes et guézy dit la population
présente aujourd'hui et arabes sunnites
à près de 100% retisser le lien prendra
du temps en irak
les blessures ont été si profond de part
et d'autre qu'il faut sans doute prendre
des précautions considérable il n'y a
pour l'instant aucune réconciliation en
vue
il faudra probablement du temps de la
patience et surtout une idée claire de
ce qu'on veut faire de la place qu'on
veut et qu'on doit accorder à chacun il
y avait un pont cela dean à bagdad il a
été débaptisée parce que ça latine c'est
le héros des sunnites et ce n'est pas le
héros du schisme il a au contraire
persécuter les chiites s'est pour
l'instant malheureusement on en est là
au moyen orient
je crois profondément que la culture
seulement ne peut pas apporter la paix
le patrimoine mais sans le respect du
patrimoine et de culture il n'y a pas de
paix durable
[Musique]
tout ce qui sera fait pour remettre en
état ce patrimoine auquel les irakiens
où les syriens sont extrêmement attachés
ce seront des signes importants d'un
retour à une certaine stabilité et une
certaine normalité donc ça c'est
extrêmement important parce que ça ça
permet aussi de montrer au monde que le
pays se reconstruit qu' il ya quelque
chose qui se passe mais ça ne peut se
faire et ça ne peut s'accompagner que
dans un contexte politique économique et
sociale
je crois qu'on ne peut pas dissocier le
culturel et la valorisation du
patrimoine des conditions dans
lesquelles les gens vivent aujourd'hui
en irak en syrie
l'urgence pour les populations c'est de
manger c'est de se soigner
c'est de reprendre une vie normale
[Musique]
je vais
à 30 km au sud de mossoul un semblant de
vie normale reprend peu à peu aux
monastères catholiques syriaques de marc
benamou
[Musique]
m
vous
[Musique]
marc behnam du nom du saint enterré en
ces lieux
[Musique]
son mausolée avait été pulvérisé à
l'explosif par des ch
il a été détruit parce que yazidi
chrétiens et musulmans prier prier dans
ce monastère
il a été détruit pour ça parce que des
jeunes supportait pas ça
sa reconstruction est vite entreprises à
l'initiative de fraternité en irak
une ong française dont le projet est
financé par alice dont le père jakub
l'abbé du monastère l'aide des habitants
de la région de toutes confessions a
également joué un grand rôle
[Musique]
enfin dans le baladeur à la mi-mars
catakit des rimes à nos intimes armleder
assassines ou chercher un entraîneur
martin mabala bajard biotope l adema ou
à torrent le dr
enfin rouge albi naadja mais c'est le
marois a terrassé le cas d'yves wajdi
mouawad bina a dit mme deen ne sied à un
petit match
yahoo a des remords à l'albanie à dire
le waka final si one of us et la farine
au délire waché et du germinal mon papa
voilà où ça arrive il ya animal man
truck à laâyoune comme ana paula m
konaté diallo
le village du mausolée s'appellerait
dire radi veut dire l'arabe le vert le
verdoyant airs à dire et est associée à
la chrétienté par elie eliassou saint
georges dans le soufisme
on nous dit il faut que tu respectes
tout le monde à travers ça tu peux
peut-être rencontrer cinar à dire et les
yézides y prirent à dire en
reconnaissance de ce qu'il a apporté et
il n'existe pas de famille yazidi où il
n'y a pas un gamin mal n'est pas prêt
non mirent à dire c'est quand même
extraordinaire ces histoires et tout ça
avec les chrétiens
[Musique]
aujourd'hui rebâti le mausolée est
désormais accessible à tous et si le
monastère restaurer porte encore
certains stigmates la vie religieuse
n'est ici lie à 1600 ans a repris
[Musique]
la paix très fragiles particulièrement
on n'a jamais gagné et c'est pourquoi la
protection du patrimoine est tellement
lié à long terme avec la paix et de
sécurité
c'est pas seulement on les construit
nous ce qu'est une église c'est vraiment
du travail
allons à longue durée
[Musique]
il ya un très grand danger en fait en ce
moment je crois dans une logique du
chacun chez soi du chacun pour soi voyez
chacun sa petite mémoire est un enjeu
important là on a beaucoup à y perdre
nous sommes tous faits d'histoire plus
grands de l'histoire de croisement
n'avons pas à être assigné strictement à
nos origines
[Musique]
il ya tant de monde qui ont passé voilà
quelque chose que les poètes de l'islam
médiéval savez bien il ya tant de monde
qui ont passé dont il ne nous reste rien
mais tout ce dont il nous reste des
traces
nous les honorons comme membres de la
famille humaine
si non alors alors ils ont raison
[Musique]
le tout
we have et moi en responsabilité du
président as tu souhaites futures
générations
avis aux passionnés t.drx peering la
terre
[Musique]
oh
pour
où
auj
[Musique]
on